thank you
welcome to this meeting of baby District
Council cabinet
I'm councilor John Ward leader of baby
District Council and I'll be chairing
this meeting
may I remind you of some domestic
Arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or Switched Off
finally we'll be using e-voting for this
meeting of the modern.gov app so please
can members make sure they are logged in
and ready to use the app
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except whether our confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
so I'd now like to move to the agenda
please
item one apologies for absence
item two to receive Declarations of
pecunery other registerable or
non-registerable interests by members
councilor arthi um with regards to the
um seal paper later on which I present I
have an interest to declare as chairman
of Lindsay Parish Council one of the
applications is in Lindsay parish and of
course Lindsay Parish Council are a
consult team
thank you very much thank you
moving on oh sorry councilor melvisi
no no
no
no
Right Moving On item three paper BCA
2228 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 3rd of October 2022.
I'll just go through those Page by Page
um this is on your modern.gov at page
five
Page Six
P seven
page eight
and page nine
if there are no questions or comments
then please may I have a proposer
councilor Osborne the seconder castle
Busby thank you
moving on I oh gosh we need to vote yeah
sorry about that thank you chair the
vote is now in progress on
councilman crawl I can't log on to the
voting cell have to vote manually in
favor in favor thank you
councilman BC
oh you just come through now thank you
very much uh soldier that is a
seven books full thank you
thank you
item four to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
Castle's petition scheme
thank you
item five questions by counselors
in item six matters referred by the
overview in scrutiny or joint audit and
standards committees there are no
matters for
thank you
item seven for forthcoming decisions
list
do any members of the cabinet have any
questions over this
the only thing I'd like to point out at
this stage is we do have a council
meeting for the schedule for the 22nd of
November there's nothing showing in the
list at the moment for that meeting
because papers haven't been prepared yet
but um
keep an eye out in the next week or so
councilor McCraw does that indicate it's
possible it will be canceled
um we're not ready with the agenda I
if there's a possibility but I hope not
because um we do there are a number of
things which I think we do need to
include on that for a council meeting
before Christmas
so for no further comments then uh
moving on to item eight
paper BCA 22 29 the tenant engagement
strategy
and I'd like to invite the cabinet
member for housing to introduce the
support councilor Osborne
chairman I'd like to introduce report
BCA 2229 which outlines our proposed
approach to tenant engagement within
housing how we plan to develop our
tenant engagement opportunities and
priorities to enable effective and
meaningful engagement with our tenants
in the form of our tenant engagement
strategy for 22-25
the strategy has been developed with our
tenants Insight following our tenant
engagement survey exercise where 1092
tenants responded to the survey which I
am sure you will agree is a fantastic
response rate and their responses have
provided invaluable Insight which has
informed the development of this
strategy
the purpose of the strategy is to ensure
our tenants are aware of the available
opportunities to be able to hold us to
account on performance influence the way
we do things and be at the center of our
decision-making processes in ways which
suit them
part of our requirement to comply with
the tenant involvement and empowerment
standard one of the consumer standards
of the regulator for social housing and
our ambition to have truly tenant-led
Housing Services we feel that this
strategy underpins those commitments and
focuses our direction of travel to
ensure we have a good tenant-led
governance structure in place
following the adoption of the strategy
and its Associated delivery plan work
will be undertaken by officers to look
at how we can recruit a representative
range of tenants to a variety of roles
laid out within the strategy ensuring we
are being inclusive in terms of offering
engagement and influence opportunities
in both physical and virtual settings
progress of the delivery plan will be
modeled monitored by the tenant board
and portfolio holders for housing as
well as the strategy itself being
reviewed at least annually the results
of which will all be reported to all our
tenants
I would therefore like to propose
recommendations to approve the strategy
as in option one of the report and ask
for a seconder myself and David White
housing transformation manager are happy
to take any questions thank you Mr Chen
thank you councilor Osborne may I have a
second to please
councilor movisi thank you
members of the cabinet does anyone have
any questions first of all
debate customer craw and then councilor
McLaren
thank you chair
um I just wanted to ask in terms of the
presentation of the data
um
to be I'm getting hot on data these days
um I'm really pleased to see that we've
got these online responses and the
postal responses and I was wondered the
reasoning behind separating the
responses from each other and tabulating
them separately it might have been
helpful to have an aggregate score
showing I mean the relative proportions
are 187 online but the rest 800 some are
in fact uh yeah 905 postal responses and
I wasn't sure if there's any need to
distinguish between the responses I mean
whether the response is received
posterally or online shouldn't really be
affecting the nature of that response so
I just wondered if it would be possible
I would have preferred the data to have
been presented
on mass aggregated I think it might have
given a slightly clearer picture not
that it's unclear but it could be
clearer
question I will go to the officer in a
moment but I think you'll find that the
reason we have to do this is we have to
be sure that we're being compliant with
the regulator and the new powers that
are coming in place I don't know if
David wants to add to that at all
uh yeah thanks uh again for your
comments and the reason we chose to lay
out in that way was because we wanted to
show that we had
um considered both whether you know both
our online respondents and uh um people
that responded by paper
um because we wanted to show that
actually there isn't much difference in
it so rather than you know for
transparency purposes we wanted to show
that actually both both sets of
respondents responded in very similar
ways
it was really just to be able to draw
conclusions from and I apologize if I'm
being nitpicky but hey that's part of
the job
Castle yeah yeah thank you and to come
back on that one you find that um
perhaps we could take your comments and
board at a later stage there's no reason
why that we can't we can't do this this
is an evolving document and uh we can
obviously take that into consideration
councilman Clara
well unless anyone
you could put their hands up you can ask
all of them now hello thank you very
much
um
very comprehensive paper and I enjoyed
reading it
um but um
as I have an affinity with regulation
and looking at the
proposed routine inspections in every
four years what form will that
inspection take
will it be planned or unplanned or and
how many people will be in the
inspecting team was that too early to be
asked in that detail
so the regulator can come and inspect
any time they like
um the changes to the the regulations
which are being debated at the moment
um actually today in the house Commons
again
um means that they used to be able to
give us 28 days notice that will be
reduced to 48 hours notice
um so it's just to show that you know we
need to be on Apple on the ball all the
time
um in terms of how that inspection would
look that hasn't been laid out yet but
it will be similar probably to kind of
what it was like back in the audit
commission days
um they'll be looking at the consumer
standards and the evidence that we need
to be gathering now and you know
providing to make sure that when the
regulator comes we can show that the you
know each standard and what's expected
of us we've got evidence to back that up
that we've met those standards
okay yes as I was familiar with the
audit commission days that's going to be
more regress than it is now
yeah it's more it's more around they've
extended their
um the remit so they've got more more
Powers
um unlimited fines you know all of those
sorts of um punitive measures as well
that they can put in place and that's
mostly what the
and it's going from reactive to
proactive so they'll be doing it if
you're a housing provider you will be
getting inspection once every four years
obviously for us it's two Sovereign
councils so potentially could be every
two years
um but at the moment it's reactive so
it's only when they're made aware of an
issue or or you're self-referred
my second question is about the tenants
board I do have a resident who is
actually on it and I think she's quite a
very good member of it
um is there a sort of public list of
members of the tenants board
and how often is there a change of
membership
I'm not sure about the list I'll refer
to David on that one because I'm not
sure of data protection where we stand
with that one so I'm not too sure in
regards to your second question
um regarding how often do they sit they
sit as and when it's required if your
paper's coming forward or there's a
policy we need their views on then
obviously they will sit at the moment
the membership is quite small but we're
working hard to improve that mentorship
as well as get a more sort of more
representation sitting on it especially
the problem is getting younger people to
sit on it in their sort of um
late 20s I suppose early 30s they're the
ones that we really need to Target a
little bit more the older ones tend to
be quite forthcoming and sitting on it
um but yeah so we'll be working hard on
that one
the
I work with the I know they sort of a
volunteer but is there a routine change
of membership
yeah
yeah thanks so the tenant board
is is part of the work to do with the
strategy we need to we've developed a
role profile so very much like a job is
good it were the problem we've got with
the tenant board at the moment is
they're both being used as a
consultative body and a scrutiny body
and the Tenant engagement
experts are basically saying that that's
not the right way of doing it you should
have a consultative body and a separate
security body so uh we need to develop
the tenant board either the current
board that we've got or as Council
Osborne's mentioned encouraging new
members through
um that will and with their sole purpose
of being asked scrutiny function so they
won't be there to to consult on policies
and things like that that we've got
other groups that can do that so yes
they're there to hold us to account on
our performance with with the
regulations
um but at the moment you know as I say
the next stage is to develop those
develop the terms of reference for the
group develop the group itself and to
make sure we've got the right skills in
place
actually sounds like a good
development
thank you
the my home bulletin can you just
I read the papers but I wasn't clear
there is it says it will be update
update
and then if if I as a resident I'm not
digitally competent I
sort of report
how often online would it be put out
so my home bulletin was introduced on
the back of our 2019 tenant satisfaction
survey where residents didn't said that
they didn't feel that we communicated
with them very well or frequently enough
so we introduced the my home bulletin
which is a monthly bulletin and it is
sent to 4 600 tenants who we hold email
addresses for every single month we can
also use it to send out um sort of short
sharp messages that we want for example
we had over last week we had some
um Focus callers so we wanted to put
that out there to make sure that
residents knew about that
in the future yes we want to be able to
develop it but we're very mindful that
it's only going to four and a half
thousand tenants so we wanted to do a an
overall one that could be
available in a physical format
um as as requested we probably won't
send it out as a matter of course
because of the the associated costs with
that but if it's requested we will be
able to do that
knows that uh
those that actually can receive and that
to me was a bit unfair if um I was just
as a resident if I was disadvantaged by
waiting for that and I can access
to the postage and it would be
phenomenal really
thank you
um
the
dashboard it's
it's the um I have got very good
eyesight because my eyes done a long
time ago but the the dark color on the
headings sort of obliterated the type in
a bit
it
is sort of just look at that the dark
red you couldn't see the the type at all
so
um I know how you know what a lot of
work it entailed but it would be helpful
if the colors were just a bit lighter
thank you thank you
Council Roswell
same problem myself
can I just
the book says to it and those that have
and we're very very
um Keen to make sure that they're not
left out of any consultation or
engagement that we do so it's very much
part of all the process that we will do
to make sure that it's fair across those
that got into
those that haven't those that have that
can't use it as well as those that have
so that is very much in our minds to
make sure that everybody everybody has
an equal opportunity
I think I'm very I think
I think I'm very aware
that we've got residents now within the
cost of
the cost of living crisis who actually
some of them are going to come offline
because he expects
explain whatever and that that group
might increase actually more than it is
at the moment but thank you David thank
you John thank you chair
are there any other questions before we
move into debate
in which case
um we'll move into cabinet debate um
just before anyone makes any extent if
they wish to uh you'll see that the uh
the paper that we've got references the
social housing white paper well there's
now legislation going through Parliament
um just in case members are unaware as a
result of that and and this this
engagement strategy leaks in very well
with that
um because that's going to give tenants
greater powers and ensure that they have
better access to um
Swift and fairy dress and also the
regulation of social housing is going to
have greater Powers
particularly around ensuring that um
serious issues regarding repairs and
maintenance are resolved a lot more
rapidly so that's all to be welcome for
for our tenants and and uh hopefully
this this engagement strategy will
um will ensure that we we
understand from the tenants themselves
exactly what they expect from the
service we're providing and I I think uh
what we've got here is is a very good
document and we'd be very happy to to
support it but um does anyone else wish
to comment
Council malvesi
will assist
baber in managing anti-social Behavior
which is a blight on social housing it
is and it's certainly one of the things
that um has clearly came back as a
result of the survey is has been um of
significant uh importance to to our
residents um thankfully it's not it
gives the tenants
those who aren't anti-social I think it
gives them a sense of somebody's caring
somebody's concerned about our
our home
it's not ubiquitous although all over
the district but there are pockets and
and some of the the issues are very
complex and do require
um a significant term and time-consuming
multi-agency response um but yes we
we're fully aware that that's something
that hopefully we'll be able to
prove and and ensure that the response
is is a lot better and we reduce the
instances of it
councilor Osborne
I'm thinking this will be the last word
on
so um
although we were all
around the work that we were doing in
regards to engagement with our and
tenants we were already doing it but
this strategy just strengthens that what
we're already doing and ensures that
we're compliant with the regulator
um but we have a very good tenant board
they're very up for engaging with us at
the moment and as I said before we
really need to get more members into get
involved into the engagement and we're
working on that in regards to the
comment about anti-social Behavior it
won't solve it completely I have to say
I don't want to raise people's
expectations and members of the public
have been listening into this it will
not resolve anti-social Behavior but it
will have give our tenants more of a say
in what we do in regards to how we uh
deal with that that actual issue
um can I take this opportunity to thank
all the officers involved for a
brilliant strategy you have to put it
together
fairly quickly and and it's I think it's
a very good piece of work and I'm sure
it will stand as in good State when the
regulator does do an inspection so well
done to all the offices involved thank
you Mr chairman
thank you Council Osborne Castle Busby
next year um
I'm slightly concerned that
we're having a tenant board that are
going to be telling us what our manager
is already ought to know
where our performance is lacking where
we're not hitting the the targets that
we've set why should we have to rely on
tenants doing that surely if you've got
the management of the right place they
all and the workers they all know
exactly what's going on
would you like to respond to that did
think I'd have the last word but knowing
David I know that's not possible
um yeah I find this question a bit
strange actually because
um yeah we do monitor our performance of
course we monitor the performance but
this is all about engaging the tenants
in that performance and giving them
ownership of that performance so I have
a bit of a problem in trying to
understand where you're coming from on
that one Council Busby perhaps you'd
like to explain a bit more I don't think
the tenant should be have the ownership
of our performance I think that should
be down to our management and the and
the cabinet
I think you'll find our tenants will
disagree with you one on that one David
and it's very clearly has come out in
the surveys but they want to take
ownership of our performance they want
to be involved in our performance so I
don't think the tenants would agree with
you on that one and this is all about
our tenants this is about listening to
our tenants hearing what they've got to
say to us and actually acting on it and
that's what we're doing
I'll just say that it
if we were doing things 100 right on and
on time
would the tenant feel the need to have a
tenant board or will they feel satisfied
is it only because we're not delivering
the right the performance that tenants
want that we're having to have these
tenants board
sorry Mr
Chen it's not this is about and we're
never going to be perfect there's always
room for improvement so let the tenants
have the opportunity to tell us where
they feel that improvement's coming from
of course we'd like to reach 100 but
that's quite unrealistic we're never
going to get there
can I bring councilman craw in I think
he he probably has a few things he'd
like to say in response I mean I'm just
looking at this why would we not want
the tenants to be able to express
themselves why would we not want to get
um experienced tenants and I
uh that you mentioned the member um of
the tenants board mentioned in the
papers that members that person is known
to me and has been a member of previous
tenants boards
um in their other incarnations but more
important thing I think here is that
this is complying with an approach
that's being made through central
government and also including the
Ombudsman and I look at the diagram at
the bottom of page 12 of the main paper
a introductory paper
and it's fairly clear that this isn't a
matter of
people owning or not owning it's that
yes we own the properties and we own the
job but that doesn't mean we shouldn't
take input from elsewhere and and I can
assure you that we don't take input from
elsewhere you're going to get it because
we get it in our walls I know I do I
know wander around the religion people
are always asking me questions on the
nature of their tenancy and sometimes I
can help them sometimes I can't but
generally speaking why would we not want
to listen to them
yeah thank you customer care
any other comments Council McLaren
oh well that's it on a similar vein to
councilor mccrroll any public service
um always needs uh the views of the
people that use that service it doesn't
matter which service we're talking about
across the country
uh even in private in something like
private businesses you you actually
engage with the people who are receiving
the service to get their views and I
think it's important
to like to engage the residents I think
they have a lot to offer actually
in contribution to what we do thank you
yeah I'd agree with that councilman uh
councilman just to summarize it's not
passing the buck which I think is the
sort of implication or denying
responsibility and ownership it's
sharing the load
nothing wrong with that thank you
Council Busby are you convinced now
laughs
I just believe I'm it's better to do
than to listen
I may be wrong we'll still be doing
okay any other comments
if not then I think it's probably time
we moved to the vote
the vote's man progress
councilman I take your vote in favor
thank you
she had that seven Roots full that's
unanimous thank you
and moving on item nine paper BCA 2230
Community infrastructure Levy the still
expenditure program for November 2022.
before I ask the government member for
planning to introduce the report I'd
just like to introduce two guests today
in relation to item three the
befriending scheme I've got Shirley
Moore the chief executive and also have
Francis Torrington and Welcome to our
meeting today
councilor arthi
thank you chair
um there are as you've said three seal
bids for cabinet to decide today
the cabinet decisions affect the
parishes of great Walden field great
cornard and Lindsay
firstly
b2208 in great wolding field which is
the upgrade of parking facilities at the
Village Hall and the seal bid is for
thirty thousand eight hundred and twenty
four pounds 92 pence from The Ring
fenced infrastructure fund still ask on
this project is 75 of the project costs
the project will increase the number of
parking spaces by 10 all inside the
Village Hall boundary providing
dedicated disabled parking spaces to
help improve the access to the building
and potentially increase the level of
use and
activities
by increasing the size of the car part
and clearly marking out parking spaces
more cars will be able to park on site
and reduce the need for village hall
users to park on the road and also
reduce the level of disruption to
Residents and other Road users
The Village Hall already has dedicated
EV charger spaces
you will send your papers that councilor
Mabry has submitted some comments on the
cell bid including that the application
States support from the Braithwaite
allotment Trust
she has said that neither she the
secretary nor the chairman as Trustees
of the trust have been consulted
she goes on to say extending the car
park onto the grassed area of the
Village Hall restricts outdoor
activities at the site which baber are
currently encouraging and that the grass
acts as a natural buffer and sound
reducer
she would prefer a sustainable grass car
park with a honeycomb type of hard
standing between which grass could be
grown and which would support Wildlife
when not in use
these concerns have been discussed with
her along with an issue she raised
concerning underground heating pipes
under the grass where the car park would
go
these pipes are dug into the ground by
one meter and would not affect the
laying of a car park
officers have also checked and a
paragraph of support has been received
from the Braithwaite allotment Trust
chairman to conclude the scheme is an
oven ready scheme with support from five
local bodies
great Walden field Parish Council the
neighborhood Steering group Slimming
World the great welding field
Horticultural Society and Suffolk County
Council plug-in Suffolk
it also has my support and the support
of the Braithwaite Trust
collaborative funding will be provided
by Great Wall and field Village Hall
management committee
it is recommended to cabinet and is the
first bid that I'm proposing to you
today
chairman moving to
b2207 in great cornard again a car park
it's the upgrade of parking facilities
at the great cornard allotment car park
a sill bit of 55
927 pounds 50 from the local
infrastructure fund
the sale ask here is 75 of the project
costs
the project involves installing a new
level tarmac stroke hard surface
and improved drainage system within the
car park
the potential for accidents and injuries
from trips and falls as a result of the
uneven surfaces and potholes should be
greatly reduced for all car park users
a hard surface with clearly marked
parking Bays will also reduce any
potential damage to vehicles
by extending the boundary of the car
park and clearly marking out parking
spaces the capacity of the car park will
be increased by 20 to 25 percent
as existing it's estimated there are 12
to 15.
spaces dependent on potholes and
flooding they say so presumably people
are parking around the potholes and
puddles so the increase would be to
about 20 maybe 25 spaces
this car park lies in close proximity to
the allotments the gains portrayal the
country Park and existing sports
facilities so we'll benefit many users
scheme again is an oven ready scheme
with community support and collaborative
funding being provided by great cornard
Parish Council
it is recommended to cabinet and is the
second bid I'm proposing for your
approval today
the third and final bid for you to
consider today is
b2209 in Lindsay
which is the befriending scheme red rose
Friends Community Farm
a sill bit of a hundred thousand pounds
which is our new maximum amount for
Community projects and it would be from
the local infrastructure fund
she'll ask is 70.4 percent of the type
of project costs of 141
981 pounds 59.
chairman before outlining the case
please can Shirley Moore the chief
executive of the befriending scheme who
you introduced earlier can she please
give a five-minute presentation on the
befriending scheme so cabinet members
will more clearly understand how the
scheme works
thank you
yes of course and Shirley if if you'd
like to speak now that would be a great
help
um to give further background for
cabinet members thank you Michelle
um good afternoon everybody thank you
very much for inviting me here today
um I'm delighted to talk about my
charity the preventing scheme we've been
in existence for 33 years
um starting off in Sudbury
and now extending our services to the
whole of Suffolk
we historically we provided a one-to-one
befriending scheme and run a number of
um Community hubs all over Suffolk
in the last few years we've developed
our services so initially we were
working simply with adults with a
learning disability but for about the
last 10 years we've extended our remit
and we now work with a lot of people who
are suffering ill mental health with
vulnerable families with military
families with older people
about
five years ago we initiated a project
working with otley college what I should
say is that throughout our existence
we've always talked to our users and
asked them what would be most beneficial
to them what what kind of services could
we provide that would give them the most
help
um and eventually overwhelmingly lots of
our members
um wanted to and lots of them wanted to
have jobs uh they wanted to have a
purpose for getting up in the morning
um and we we kind of hit on when when we
when we drilled that down
um what was really quite popular was the
idea of of working outside working with
animals
working on the land so hence the the
idea of a community Farm arose and we
initially set up with otley college who
are very keen for us to come on to their
campus and and starter pilot there which
we did quite successfully until
eventually otley College were taken over
and they no longer had that facility
available
from them we
um because we knew how well it had
worked we wanted to set up
um another Farm which we did in
Essington about three and a half four
years ago
that has been such a huge success in
terms of the services and the benefit
that we've been able to provide for a
whole range of people as I said our main
client group is adults with a learning
disability but more and more we've been
working with people who are suffering
from illness
um we have for example a project called
mindful Mondays
where we are providing a service for
ladies particularly who have been
struggling and haven't been able to
get enough
um benefit from the National Health
Service from
the IDT and actually Francis who's my
Deputy chair she she volunteers at
online for Mondays
so if you'd like any case studies for
particularly what how how we benefit
some people I'm sure Francis would be
happy to elaborate
um
the the care Farm in assington was
amazing still is amazing we are still
there we're in the process of moving
right now
um we had originally thought that if the
farm was a success that we could have
had some additional land in Essington
but that didn't happen and because we
were so successful we really wanted to
find bigger premises where we could
provide more services for more people
so I did note that there was something
about that maybe we'd technically failed
in Essington and I I genuinely don't
think we have I think that the benefit
that we've been able to provide for the
local community has been immense
um
and in fact gives you a flavor of the
befriending scheme and the kind of
services that we provide but happy to
take any questions
thank you Shirley um I'll let councilor
arthi finish his his introduction and
then when we come to questions I'm sure
there will be some for you but um thank
you for that that's very helpful
kasarathi you want me to continue yes
please okay well thank you Shirley
um for for that and thank you chairman
for allowing Shirley to come and talk to
us today
um
this is a Unique sell bid in that this
befriending scheme proposal is one that
baber funded through seal in assington
previously for 26 043 pounds with
approximately 12 000 pounds of
communities Grant
the scheme started in 2019 and the sill
stroke community's money was paid out to
support the venture
but the relationship between the
operator and the farmer who gave them a
lease has since completely broken down
he has terminated the lease and we
understand it has only a few weeks left
to run
the reasons for this breakdown have not
been formally stated and it has been
difficult to pinpoint reasons
the befriending scheme have secured a
new lease at a farm in Lindsay and have
applied for further seal funding of a
hundred thousand pounds for a total
project startup cost of a hundred and
forty one thousand pounds
their intention is to move the operation
to Lindsay and they have plans to expand
the operation including education
elements
all the checks and balances for this new
sealed beard have been undertaken by
Christine and her team
sorry
um
and the scheme meets the framework
requirements with all the necessary
evidence for costings as the sealed bid
however there are confidence and
Longevity issues around the operation
given that the site at assington has
effectively failed and this is a second
request for investment from seal for a
relaunch of the Venture AT Lindsay and I
will cover these details later
although planning permission has been
granted for the befriending scheme using
Lindsay there were local objections on
Highway and traffic grounds which were
looked at by highways and ultimately the
use was accepted
consultation has occurred on this seal
bid and brought forward objections from
the parish
they are supportive of the change of use
but objections raised to the sighting of
the porter cabins and the storage
containers due to their appearance and
impact on the landscape
concerns also raised in terms of impact
on highway safety given the increase in
vehicle movements along a classified
road which is narrow
the ward member councilor Jameson is
undecided
these localized objections are important
and should be given weight in any
decision but it is important to
recognize that this befriending scheme
would have wider benefits for baber
residents and users of the facility as
there are no other such schemes across
the whole of the baber district
it has been a very difficult situation
upon which our officers have based a
recommendation
the earlier still investment has to some
extent been safeguarded by the proposed
transfer of the porter cabin and fencing
from assington to Lindsay
but similar circumstances of this sill
bid also relate to the silverian
assington if they are compared
in Lindsay the land is leased for 25
years with the first break Clause at
year five which is the same Arrangement
as the land at assington and the minimum
we require for provision of permanent
infrastructure
costs are greater for the startup at
Lindsey than compared with assington
with 100 000 pounds being sought
compared to 26 000 pounds previously
accounts have been requested for
assington from the operator
but they are not available as the only
accounts that are accessible are for the
befriending scheme in totality
our officers have tried to make contact
with the farmer who ended the Essington
lease to find out why the relationship
broke down but as far as I'm aware no
new information has been forthcoming
chairman to conclude this sill bid is a
second sill bid for an expansion of a
care Farm facility and project
together with movement of the facility
to a different location at Lindsay
there are localized objections to this
bid but benefits for The Wider District
confidence could be low around longevity
and risks could be argued to be high
based on the operation ceasing at
assington
our Shield team are recommending this
bid to you given the widespread benefits
that would accrue to the district by
continuing to support the scheme it is
recommended for approval as an exception
to the normal approach to seal bid offer
Letters by making the recommendation for
approval subject to the imposition of a
clawback provision such that if the use
fails within 10 years All the Monies are
clawed back through a condition on the
sill bid offer letter
Financial accounts show that the general
befriending scheme currently have
reserves of around 500 000 pounds in
their funds to cover this
our shared legal service have confirmed
that this clawback provision is
appropriate in the circumstances and
chairman the officer recommendation is
one of approval
finally chairman I am proposing approval
of the first two bids under 3.1 but
given my position as chairman of Lindsay
Parish Council I am asking you to take
bid through at Lindsay separately
chairman at 3.2 I'm also asking cabinet
to note and endorse the sill expenditure
program at appendix a
thank you thank you Council rathi
um right uh I'd like for a second for
the first two bids please and uh
councilman McLaren we will be discussing
and voting on those first two separate
from the last one
but I'm prepared to um happy to propose
the the third bid for the befriending
scheme and I would like a second for
that councilor Osborne thank you very
much so first of all what I'd like to do
is to ask members of the cabinet if you
have any questions on either the first
two bids
Jim can I ask if there are questions
addressed uh Shirley would you allow her
to answer yes of course yes yes
so just just focus on on the first two
the two car parts that um Greg Wally
field and great cornard any questions on
either of those two
Council Osborne
betrayal for anybody to start walking on
the courtyard section that's where they
will park their cars
um can I can we assume that uh it will
be free to park there and there won't be
any charges is that a criteria for the
silvied or could be introduced at a
later stage okay Council Arthur yes
please yeah it applies to all seal bids
other than if you remember I think it
was the last meeting you approved that
uses such as
museums gainsbury's house things like
that in general we would not allow seal
to be spent on something that didn't
allow full Public Access free
do you remember we did have a brief
discussion on it so the answer is no
there would be no charge
thank you
any other questions on those first two
and does anyone wish to make any
comments in debate on those first two
are you Council Busby what's the
question really um councilor off you've
read some
suggestions recommendations from
councilor Mabry
will they be taken up or not
regarding the um sorry the type of
surface yeah
um no we're considering
um the scheme as applied as I understand
it councilor Mabry did have a discussion
with the with the sill team
they addressed I think most of her
concerns
um with regard to her
suggestion that perhaps some sort of
reinforced plastic mesh
could be used rather than a Tarmac
surface
the applicant has not amended their
their bid
any other comments councilman RVC
chairman
really
um who's going to maintain these two car
parks
that's Rafi
the applicants
so in the case of great waldenfield
Committee in the case of
um
great cornard I'm struggling a bit I'm
guessing it's going to be the parish
council but I'm just going to check with
Christine Thurlow
it's one of the questions
still bid application form you have to
put in a maintenance agreement or a plan
to look after the investment that is
gained through sales so I'm thinking
that that is Parish Council because they
were the sell bed author
thank you Chrissy
okay if there are no other questions or
comments we could perhaps move to the
vote on those first two
sorry Council Oswald
sorry Mr chairs just normally you go to
other councilors to see if they've got
any questions oh
Council Hinton do you have any other
questions
thank you Mr chairman thank you Council
Elizabeth bringing that up
um
the only question I've got really is
we're talking here about these two
applications so the increasing car
parking size whereas at last
cabinet meeting uh there was a there was
a car parking a parking strategy put
forward which was also heavily
emphasizing the reduction in the use of
the Reliance on the car rather than
increasing the use of the car whereas
here we're talking about effectively
enabling the increase in the use of the
car just seems a little bit of a a
contradiction in terms I'd like to hear
some comments on on that
I'm
I can respond with regard to great
waldenfield
and currently there are people who
arrive by car and park on the grass in
the summertime that's not a problem in
the winter time it makes a mess they
also have situations where they have
cars parking out on a busy road so that
people could people can access events at
the Village Hall so I don't think this
will increase the use of cars
I think it will have no impact it may
well increase the use of the hall but
that doesn't necessarily mean that
everybody will be arriving by car the
other thing is they've lost a couple of
regular spaces in their car park because
they've installed EV charging points so
those are dedicated for Ev users
I have to confess I'm not as familiar
with that application
um I don't know I'm looking at Christine
Thurlow and she's got her hand on the
loudspeaker button so hopefully she can
help you with that one
thank you uh as some of you will know
Black House Lane which is the main
access to that car park is very narrow
it is an area which is used not only for
the allotments but for the Gainsborough
Trail and then you've got Sports users
taking place down Black House Lane where
no doubt there are congestion issues so
this is resurfacing and marking out
spaces more effectively which I think
will help aid congestion and address
live issues from a parking point of view
the car park can also be used by cycle
users of course
Council RVC did you want to come back on
that parking issue yes chairman
address the comment that councilor
Hinton made the parking strategy
doesn't actively go against the use of
cars it looked at
location of car parks
and the best use of car parks and to
allocate parking within car parks that
removes parking on grass verges that
does damage to our environment
key
thank you councilman BC Council Osborne
it's about making the allotments and the
walks and the health center more
accessible because currently in the
winter it's a mud bath so people can't
park their cars there to use those
services so it's not about increasing
it's about making parking easier
thank you
any more from anyone
okay
we will move to the vote now
thank you on the first two items only
the two car parts
chairman to be clear we're taking 3.2 as
well I'm sorry I'm 3.2 as as it's um
the um yes members are voting on
recommendation 3.1 excluding silbid
b22-09 and recommendation 3.2 as
detailed in the report
take your vote please in favor thank you
thank you chair that's seven votes four
thank you okay then uh we're now moving
on to the um uh the befriending schemes
uh application but you've you've heard a
lot from uh councilor Rafi and you've
also heard from Shirley Moore
um
planning permission has been granted for
this
there were highways issues
but uh
analysis of traffic movements and and
vehicle volumes were provided and
Suffolk highways were
did accept the the data that was
provided and felt that the application
uh met all of their criteria for um the
the access to the road
um new visibility supplies are going to
be put in place and there was no concern
from highways over those traffic volumes
um
there are a number of other points that
councilor arthi has has raised there and
and perhaps he'd like to
examine those either three questions or
debate but first of all I'd like to open
it up for cabinet member questions
either of um councilor arthy or indeed
of Shirley Moore or Francis Torrington
who are both here
councilor Osborne
Mr chairman good afternoon Shirley
welcome to the cabinet meeting
um excellent scheme this one absolutely
excellent but my question is um num how
many people do you envisage being able
to take advantage of the scheme when it
moves over and how accessible will it be
because obviously
essendon wasn't that accessible either
and I didn't think he even had a bus
route to it so how do you propose to
make this more accessible
so um since we started Essington we have
actually got a mini bus
so we do pick up our members at the
moment at uh Kingfisher Leisure Center
in Sudbury and we've proposed to
continue to do that to really good
location to be able to bring people to
Lindsay
um some of the parent carers will come
along and drop their cared for person
off with us
we envisage that will also be attracting
members from Hadley and I guess because
of the rural position
people will be coming in in cars but
because we have the minibus we'll be
bringing perhaps the bulk of our members
via minibus so
traffic I know there was a big concern
about traffic but in in terms of when
the traffic will be there there'll be
five or six staff including a minibus
driver over a period of about an hour in
the morning and then again in the late
afternoon so it won't be a an all-day
traffic in and out
sorry what was your other question Jen
was that about numbers yeah actually the
um the transport side of it obviously
highways have looked at it and they're
fine with it and I think the benefit's
far outweigh the possible minor impact
that they'll be on on the infrastructure
my other question was how many people do
you envisage over a period say of five
years being able to take advantage of
the facility yeah okay so I I think that
um it will be much greater than we have
a ass in
have two Porter cabins there
um by the way just while I'm talking
about Porter cabins what we will be
doing and I think it it was perhaps if
not in the silver then certainly in the
planning that we will timberclad the
porter cabin building so that they will
look more like farm buildings
um I'm really Keen to make sure that
aesthetically they look really good and
are in keeping with the surrounding area
so I I anticipate that we'll have maybe
25 people a day but what I'm also hoping
is that we'll have
certain days for the community which we
weren't able to do at attington
um and I'm I'm also pleased to say that
I know there have been some objections
from the parish council but we've
already had
um several people who live in and around
Lindsay who'd like to volunteer and are
very supportive of the project so I'm
I'm heartened by that at least that it's
it's not the whole of um who are
well if I could just add to that
um I'm not quite sure um whether it
covers Council Osborne's question but I
think it does
um on the application form
um there there's a question
um about the um the number of users and
so the response that was in the
application form is that the befriending
scheme itself will have 75 users a week
the local special schools including
Hillside and I don't know if I
pronounced this property dashcroft is it
is 30 pupils per month Local Schools
four class visits per year local
residents and volunteers 15 to 20 per
week and Community groups beavers Brands
and Scouts is is down as several pack
visits throughout the year and then
we've got send students 10 per week okay
so those are the numbers that were put
in as the proposal if you like for the
expansion of the facility does that help
last second
yes
I'm just I'm sitting here and I'm
thinking my mind's going round and round
round and I'm thinking people with
mental health problems you also help
them as well
will you be taking on referrals from
organizations for example the kernos
center in Sudbury will you be able to
because it sounds like you're going to
have an awful lot of people passing
through your doors but will you be in a
position to be able to take referrals
from people that have got mental health
problems as well
were already in contact with Jason
Joseph and with the IDT and bury Saint
Edmunds and in fact the mindful Mondays
project that I was talking about earlier
um those were referrals from the IDT who
couldn't provide what those ladies
needed so yes in in uh it's a
long-winded way of saying yes we
certainly will
do you expect to have people coming from
Stone market now if you moved to Lindsay
you'll be a lot closer to Stone Market
and sort of within the catchment I mean
yes yes it certainly could be I think
we'll we'll see how things go certainly
Hadley because Hadley is the the nearest
town we've just started to make some
contacts in Hadley but we will
fortunately be able to bring all our
members who currently go to assington
which is which is great thank you
councilman crawl
thank you chair and thank you very much
Shirley and Francis for coming along
today
um because I do think we have a lot of
questions and the sun came up in earlier
discussion of this
um so the first thing is a I wonder if
we can just get a rough comparison in
size compared to the assington site and
this site and Lindsay
um
double the size I can tell you asking us
attorneys 1.47 because and Lindsay is
4.4 so quite a substantial difference to
that might account for some
um because that's what I was really
going to get at is what is 142
000 buy that you need obviously I'm
pleased to hear about the rusticated
porter cabins that seems to me very
sensible in a beautiful place like
Lindsay councilor arthi
um but you know that that's fine but I
just wondered what exactly it is you
have to get I mean I don't know how much
sheep cost
not really about the animals I know no
no I was being a little facetious there
I apologize yeah no no no not at all no
I'm but it's just you know putting on
the utilities really is the biggest
expense
by Far and Away that's that's really
what the the bid is does this involve
running costs or is it entirely Capital
setup and Arrangements I know that
that's not necessarily allowed in still
but I think it's always worth making
sure people are aware of the distinction
how do you manage your running costs is
that something you've got under control
as a registered charity because I can
see you've got an increment
um I do apologize may I carry on chair
I've marked a few things from Pages 50
and uh 49 and 50 which raise a lot of
the points um you haven't we haven't got
accounts from the ashington site is it
possible to make any sort of estimate on
the basis of the befriending scheme in
totality like What proportion assington
was of the totality is if that's
relevant even
like to guess I'd have to ask my finance
manager to give you quite right not not
to guess that's okay
um
and the clawback provision is something
that the charity is happy to enter into
and and obviously clearly importantly
you have the funds in your reserves to
cover that
because that's a crucial aspect I'd like
to give members to be aware of that uh
in the aftermath of the Essington I
think failure is too strong a word but
it has happened but in the aftermath of
that we have a risk profile to look at
and we have to work out so this seems to
me to cover that and I think with all
those questions satisfied I'd be happy
to support this bid councilor I say view
anything further for me thank you
councilman
I was just going to add some information
to answer your parts of your question
um when you look at the application form
you did question
um
quantum of some costs utility
installation that's electricity water
and sewage is
well over fifty thousand pounds right
it's a remote site
so they need a car just a style biod of
just a plant and they need to get
electricity and water to the site so
that is quite a large proportion of the
cost I think it's only fair I mean you
may well have picked it up in the papers
yourselves but if you haven't
both the planning application and the
sill application were accompanied by a
statement from the applicant and part of
that said the project will be overseen
by a Steering group of local interested
members of the community including
representatives from the parish council
local primary school and local residents
and businesses
it says we are looking at introducing an
associate membership scheme so that the
local community can have a voice and be
part of the development of the project I
think it's only fair to say that we did
go back and ask
and the answer is no but that they will
be engaging with the parish council and
the and the local community when they've
got the planning permission and the
funding in place so I think that's
correct isn't it I'm looking at Shirley
really
the offer to come and speak to the
parish council in late spring I think to
talk about the project and in fact
introduce all those things but I didn't
actually hear back from
you will have an invitation in your
inbox when you get home I think
um but I just thought it was because
that was in your papers nobody asked the
question chairman but I thought it was
um useful to actually put that in
because it's a question that's been
asked of a befriending scheme that they
have responded to oh uh well uh well
thanks for drawing that to our attention
councilor arthi and and um thank you for
making sure that the invitation to go to
the Paris council is me
um first of all uh I've got
sorry to do this again it's just
following on from councilorati's
information would that be I mean I
looked at the technical assessment but
actually the information you've provided
is in excess of that
the technical assessment which is
appendix B
uh doesn't didn't actually contain that
information actually I'm wondering that
in cases like this where we're
considering future syllabids
um where this might be relevant and an
obvious question if you don't mind by
saying to ask that it could be included
in the technical assessment presented to
Cabinet it's just a suggestion
that's an interesting suggestion from
memory I think we used to include the
whole application of form in the cabinet
papers and I think somebody said we
don't need to have the whole of every
application form but I think in some
instances it might be useful to have
some highlights added
to compromise between the full
questionnaire which I agree with you is
probably over overly fussy
but let's be I'm just being minorly
fussy Christine and I do apologize is
that okay councilor Arthur absolutely
um I I will try
um to give you a breakdown
um in the utility installations in
Stallone
well I haven't
if you want to it's not that long
um in in the um in the section on
utility installation there are sums of
forty two thousand seven thousand nine
hundred and fifty seven thousand nine
hundred and fifty and
3232 pounds all subject to vat
um they've then got disabled ramps
disabled paths and car parking
um that's about 23 000 pounds there's a
porter cabin building sixteen thousand
five hundred a secure farm gate
1970 no vat and a fully compliant
disabled bathroom just under seven
thousand Pounds
cancel my VC
chairman um I just wanted some
clarification
viewing Us on YouTube
um and as councilor McCraw said
failure is possibly a bit uh strong
um what exactly does councilor McCarthy
mean by failure at assington
um
okay well
when we're looking at sill funding we
go to Great Lengths through Christine
team to ensure that we're putting money
into a viable proposal which has life to
it we our minimum requirement as I said
earlier on is a lease of 25 years
minimum 25 years
the reason for the comment about risk is
that those same criteria apply to
ashington
few years down the road that lease is
being terminated
we provide sill funding for permanent
infrastructure we don't provide still
funding for things like tables and
chairs we provide sill funding for the
permanent infrastructure
oddly enough some of the permanent
infrastructure that we pay for at
assington can now be moved to Lindsay so
perhaps it wasn't quite as permanent as
we thought it was but I think the
important thing to remember is that we
are looking to the life of a provision
being a minimum of 25 years and given
what's happened at assington
one has to point out to you the caution
in the fact that a similar scheme that
we have funded has has come to an end
because of the lease requirements and
the lease termination in in just a few
years
so that is a risk as I understand it the
person who has granted the lease here is
absolutely committed to a minimum 25
years but it does have the five-year
break clause in it as did the previous
lease so it it is the minimum
requirement for us to release sill funds
to community projects
fine thank you um
but one has to always bear in mind that
if you don't own
the land of Lock Stock and Barrel
you will always run the risk
of a break clause and that's not
necessarily the Charity's failure
that's possibly the failure of the
person that granted the lease in the
first instance
and not appreciating or recognizing just
what a service to the community this
charity offers
okay
um I I think though that it would be
wrong if with a figure as large as a
hundred thousand pounds which is the
maximum amount that you can award on a
and we've only just increased it to a
hundred thousand I think it would be
wrong if you weren't made aware of the
potential risks because you are dealing
with a hundred thousand pounds of money
that we have collected from developers
which is
um for the for the provision of
infrastructure and and this cabinet has
to satisfy itself
um with regard to the the viability of
the project and if it did fail in in
four or five ten years I think it would
be reasonable for people the general
public to actually look at you us
um and how we made that award
absolutely
but I think the use of the word failure
is a bit harsh because they haven't
failed the landlord has failed but I
don't think the charity has failed
thank you
actually can I just follow up on this
Shirley
um is there anything you can tell us
about what happened at Essington and any
reassurance you can give us that you're
taking the right steps
um to ensure that there is longevity
at Lindsay and that um you will be
staying there yeah
I I don't know how much
um I'd like to say about the current
landlord at Essington but what I will
say is that our new landlord has is not
only fully supportive but has actually
um written to say that he would not
enforce the five-year breaks at all so
he's he's written a letter that is
legally binding to say that he won't do
that that's how
house safe and secure he feels about our
tenure there
thank you for that
perhaps just pursuing that same question
um I don't know if Christine can help us
I think approaches were made
to the existing landlord
but I don't think any any significant
response was received or if any
one that the team attended but it was
certainly one that an officer of the
council went to but I don't think
there's anything that I could give you
tangibly to explain this and I don't
think it would be appropriate to be
guessing
um
before I go to councilman crore Council
McLaren uh had her hand up before
can I address my questions to Shirley
yes of course rather than counselor
I just want to get and Shirley I've got
to come first this is I really had to do
my homework because I'd not come across
your charity before
so I went online and practically so some
of the questions are pretty basic but I
just want to get my head before we make
this decision and I want to get my head
behind the charity itself I think
um
you are dealing with a white a wide
range of them
health
conditions in your your clients or your
I do you use the word clients or to use
the word members members yeah that's far
more respectful isn't it
um so a wide range of health conditions
that are being catered for
um but you're not subject to any
regulatory framework are you Charities
commission okay but but the care that
you're providing because care is it
cares it's called care Farm
yes it's it's the the care Farm is
therapeutic so so I I couldn't find that
on the I've got to say I knew the answer
really to that but you're not subject to
any regulatory
anyway
um
because of this wider range I mean it's
really about health and well-being
so that's part of my portfolio so I'm
really interested in this
um do you have any relationship then
with Suffolk County Council and sort of
adult social care send Children's
Service all of those okay but my last
question really we're back to the
funding because you you sort of
disclosed
the details of what what's in the bank
but how do you how do you fund the
charity what funding is there available
to you okay so
um
since a lot of grant funding finished I
think all Charities were encouraged
really to become more like businesses
which is what we kind of attempted to do
to become like a business and I will say
that at the care Farm we are we do have
a few little social Enterprises so we
have a link with the Angel hotel we're
supplying herbs and we have a stall on
the market
um but actually our our main money comes
still from funding from trusts so I
spend a great deal of my time writing
funding applications but what we get is
spot purchasing from the council so
although the the grants per se the main
prevention grants went some time ago
that's sort of replaced by spot
purchasing and also by members having
their own money and deciding how they
want to spend that
so that's how we fund the data so it's
you know as many different areas as we
can find to fund the charity
councilman crawl
thank you chair um yeah I'm just going
to return to this question of risk why
I'm a little less concerned about it
than I might have been
um whatever we say about the current
attempt and Lindsay um
Shirley's expressed some confidence in
the 10th the landlords
intentions for the next 25 years whether
or not the five-year break Clause is or
isn't used
um
the befriending scheme have the
confidence and enough confidence to
supply the clawback provision in a civil
condition and I think that's the
important point is this is public money
we are here to protect the use of public
money and make sure that it doesn't go
to any form of I'm going to use the word
yeah but that's whatever it is
protectors we can be and the and the
befriending scheme are prepared to put
their money where their mouth is
effectively well I don't think we
shouldn't
thank you councilman crawl
um I've got a quick question for
Christine actually
um
utilities connections
is still available to cover connecting
even instances like this yes
that is something that is seen as
infrastructure and eligible under the
still expenditure framework
thanks for that
are there any other questions uh I know
we've kind of straight into debate with
uh that's the right Council of crawl
um
in which case I'm happy to move into
debate does anyone want to say anything
more uh that hasn't been covered in
questions councilor Osborne
I think there's always going to be a
risk with any project like this there's
always going to be a risk but the
benefits to this far outweigh those
risks and if we were to take that into
consideration and not approve anything
because of it we wouldn't move on and
um
services such as the one that the
befriending scheme provides wouldn't be
there for us and I you know I appreciate
the concerns that the local residents
have raised and I can understand where
they're coming from but you know this
type of scheme is so badly needed and
it's becoming more and more critical and
actually I know a case study myself one
of my young residents
um has used the facility in essendon for
18 months now
and 18 months he would not walk out of
his front door he was just a shell and
now he he is so confident in yourself he
could actually go out now and apply for
a job and get it because he is just a
completely different
completely different person and it makes
me a little bit emotional to think about
it to see the change in this young
gentleman yeah so I you know I support
this 150 percent and I want to thank you
for the splendid work that you're doing
with it you're making a difference to a
lot of people's lives
thank you yeah I think I'd like to
reiterate that it's certainly clearly a
charity that that really does make a
difference and uh I'm mindful of um
obviously there were some issues with
the Paris Council and the local
community Through the planning process
and
um but I I'm heartened the fact that you
are going to be working with them the
invitation to the Paris council meeting
is coming and and but working more
closely with with the community there I
think is is essential to to ensure that
you become part of that Community
um and they can see the benefits of
having you there
uh Castle Hinton is chair of ons did you
want to say anything I have only gone
chairman but any questions I had have
already been asked by other people so
does anyone else wish to say anything
more
councilman VC and then Council McLaren
um I agree with
I think is virtually a crime
it's a service that the statutory
agencies are failing to deliver and
it is something that will be
increasingly required
especially with a cost of living crisis
um so I commend that this that we
granted thank you
thank you thank you Council McLaren
you can't put a price on that but what
it does for them and their families and
therefore
I think
for families especially in the in the
situation we find ourselves as a nation
families with
um members of their family who are
having difficulties whatever that is if
that can be supported and helped then
I'm all for that
thank you thank you Council Karen
um councilor Adrian Osborne sitting at
the back there um did you actually uh or
to ask anything I'm sorry I should have
gone to you earlier
Mr chairman I to um ah it's on
uh has been associated with the problems
of Essington and particular
um
young people that were in Sudbury and
all I can say is my concern was over
transport however your presentation
answered all those questions and that of
councilor Arthur so well done and it's a
really good scheme and I agree with my
other counselor
[Laughter]
thank you very much thank you
thank you for that yeah I I think we all
understand that the benefit of of the
friendly scheme
um and uh notwithstanding the
circumstances of the departure from
assington it's clear that something that
there needs to be continuity they've
found a new site
um they've overcome all of the obstacles
and and issues around that site and I I
think really we we need to proceed with
this and and wish them well in in
continuing and expanding at the new site
uh as councilman Mclaren has said
well-being is is an increasing part of
uh the uh the work that we do for our
communities in ensuring that we we
maintain the well-being of our residents
and communities
um I know that uh it is controversial
but
um
it's it's something that our residents
are increasingly expecting of us so we
we must make it clear that we're doing
everything we can uh to to help and
improve the well-being of our residents
because
as part of their General Health
it's it's essential because it it
ensures that they they're less reliant
on
um the services of councils and and the
the Health Service and uh it allows them
to to leave better lives so
I'm uh very supportive of this
um I think we've got to a stage now
where we can go to the vote unless
anyone wishes to say anything more the
um
uh
The Proposal here for the hundred
thousand pounds has been proposed and
seconded so
I'd like to open it up to the vote on
this item on the agenda please
thank you
thank you chair that is seven votes uh
six votes four and one abstention
thank you right well that brings us to
the close of today's meeting
um thank you councilors and thank you
Shirley thank you Francis for coming
along and thank you officers for your
input uh thanks Christine and the next
meeting is scheduled for Monday 5th of
December at 2PM